hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer weiteren
episode ich trink doch you say
normalerweise zeige ich euch ja immer zu
beginn der episode das beste tipp der
woche von eurem lieblings tik tok user
laser luca der soll allerdings ja gerade
krank und körper
von daher würde ich sagen ich hab kein
bock mehr
[Musik]
ich schwöre ich will es nicht direkt
jetzt zu beginn sagen aber es ist die
wahrheit man krabbelt er so irgendwie
mit seinen händen außenwelt als dass man
mit den füßen wieder den boden berührt
seien die wahnsinnig wie er gesteht dass
71 prozent wasser
95 prozent von diesen unentdeckt das
heißt 67 stellt ist noch nicht entdeckt
steinheim hat vor was ist alles geben
könnte wahre octopus h möglich
schokoladen papageien sich ein
kilometerlanger elefanten fisch wer
kennt ihn nicht den ein kilometer langen
elefantenfuß
deutlich
[Musik]
wie kommt man auf so eine idee
aber es ist leider wirklich die wahrheit
[Musik]
alles klar der einfach mal 17
weintrauben mund stecken und verrecken
[Musik]
ok damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet
pogo also live act 10.000 durch die
polizei holen will sagt einfach nie
ja bitte schön
mitarbeiterin woche leitet kannst du
bitte die kids aufmachen regel und
richtiges oberwart eo schlinge mit
straße werde ohne ordentlich hingekriegt
du kleiner gebaut hat einfach für video
so getan als würde sich in ihren eigenen
locker setzen aber hat eigentlich nur
den genommen der halt da gerade offen
herum stand hat sich da rein gesetzt und
ihre freundin und dann wirklich die tür
zugemacht
also ich hoffe
[Musik]
das tik tok an sicherheit ich gar nicht
so witzig aber einfach so random am ende
seine backpfeife weil es halt geschenkt
hat
[Musik]
wieso
ja ich habe bei jeder szene nach einem
herzinfarkt bekommen so einen
schwachsinn communications
[Musik]
das gucke ich mir ja auf diesem schild
steht reserviert dabei wird hier gar
nichts serviert das liegt daran dass ein
reh
davor steht
heute mal nicht blockieren von tecdoc in
eine süße stimme in eine tiefe stimme
was sage ich mache zu lesen einen süßen
stimme und nativen blieb starb jetzt hat
er seit stopp
hätte sich der satz heads up wird
natürlich ihr seid stopp ausgesprochen
[Musik]
dankeschön für den ohren krebs lucia ist
jetzt mit der techno
[Musik]
so hatte ich in meinem kopf weh getan
sag mal habt ihr euch auch schon gefragt
warum es an einem poster die stufe 6
geht ich mache ist irgendjemand sagen wo
heute habe ich mal richtig bock auf ein
stück butter
[Musik]
ich hätte gerne grosspeter mit alles
dativ ok malaga haben wir aktiv da ich
meine da tief heißt mit allem so mit
allen malaga ist heute allem daran
schuld
vor allem ist heute nicht da
es ist einfach immer so naja die nächste
person zeigt euch auf jeden fall trassen
live-act dich noch mal an
ich bin gar nicht weil du hässlich
[Musik]
es ist die wahrheit
wir klingen jetzt bei mir ein paar
sekunden später hat sich an der tür
vertan
doch jetzt hat freunde
sie werden verdächtigt steuern zu
hinterziehen ich hab doch noch nicht
gezahlten steuern hinterziehen genau das
junge damals ist steuerhinterziehung
kennen sie das gedicht frühlings glaube
von möglich und ich kann das analysieren
ich kann nichts auflösen pro phase meter
phase einer phase tello phase sie sind
unmöglich jetzt kommen sie mit nein ich
kann auch eines sagen ich schreiben
ja das deutsche schulsystem ist echt
super last draußen essen okay
ja das ist mein mann millionen in mein
leben
[Musik]
wie kommst du darauf ich hätte ein
bisschen mit meinem spiel
nein
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht
warum tik tok mir sowas auf meine for uk
packt allerdings will ich an der stelle
des heutigen video beenden weil der
lieben freunde wenn euch der heutigen
episode ticker gefallen hat dann zeigt
mir gern mit einem daumen hoch unter dem
video schreibt mir gerne euren tik tok
namen und in die kommentare falls ihr
bock habt in die nächste episode
tinc-news der nächste woche dienstag
bereiten zu kommen und ich habe sogar
noch ein tick tock für euch was auch so
ein bisschen in die richtung schulsystem
geht das war nicht so ganz versteht also
viel spaß jetzt bei den letzten tick
tock und ich bin raus
[Musik]